la capoeira è un'arte marziale e nasce
in brasile dagli schiavi africani i
quali dopo giornate di lavoro forzato
venivano riportati nelle senza la che
erano delle vere delle vere prigioni e
all'interno di questi spazi hanno dato
vita alla capo era come un momento
importante per rilassare il corpo e la
mente e per riuscire anche in qualche
modo in una situazione così difficile a
immaginare un futuro di libertà
quindi veramente possiamo dire che la
capoeira nasce come lotta di liberazione
io inizio il mio percorso nella capoeira
12 anni fa presso la scuola accademia
sul da bahia a milano il mio insegnante
e mostrando pedro allievo di mestre era
hinson che cosa mi ha affascinato
tantissimo della capoeira è un'arte è
un'arte profonda c'è la lotta quindi c'è
la competizione ma c'è l'unione c'è la
musica c'è la danza c'è il canto c'è la
cultura e quindi nella sua armonia
veramente sono riuscito a trovare
qualcosa di importante che riusciva a
dare pace ha più parti diverse di me
il burkina faso altrettanto è un paese
importante nella mia vita ci viaggio da
più di vent'anni è un paese duro come la
maggior parte dei paesi dell'africa sub
sahariana e non solo le situazioni di
disagio non sono qua adesso oggi a
raccontarle sono evidenti nel 2000 nel
2009 nasce con un gruppo di amici di
persone stupende l'associazione colón
candia italia onlus che si dedica
veramente a due obiettivi progetti di
impresa sociale progetti di inclusione
sociale
perché perché dall'esperienza dalla
sensibilità dalla capacità di viaggiare
di stare con le persone ci rendevamo
conto che erano i due punti cardini su
cui costruire dei progetti impresa
sociale perché impresa il lavoro non è
solo reddito e dignita e è confronto e
inclusione sociale perché è necessario
lavorare con i giovani perché i giovani
sono il nostro futuro non solo in
burkina faso e ed è proprio all'interno
di questo contesto che nel 2012 inizia
al progetto di capo era con il
beneplacet fondamentale di mestre rais
dimostrando pedro che sono i supervisori
della parte tecnica
l'associazione ovviamente con entusiasmo
abbracciato questo progetto perché
perché la capoeira diventa il fulcro lo
strumento per un progetto educativo
molto più ampio perché proprio per la
sua poliedricità la capo era ci permette
di lavorare con i ragazzi perché
intrigante c'è la lotta c'è l'acrobatica
c'è la disciplina però c'è il sorriso mi
piace dire a volte che la cattura e
proprio educare con il sorriso e c'è la
musica e c'è la storia c'è la cultura e
quindi ai talmente tante cose con cui
attrarre i ragazzi e con loro costruire
un percorso di fiducia senza fiducia non
si possono fare percorsi insieme e tanto
più con i giovani ed oggi ad oggi 2016
quindi dopo sei anni questo progetto è
qualcosa di solido con gli sforzi di
tutti veramente di tutti e è una scuola
oggi abbiamo 53 allievi di capo era che
vanno dai 6 anni ai 22 che frequentano
ogni settimana i corsi di capoeira e
possiamo dire che il centro giù nella
seconda città o bijoux lassù dove
abbiamo la sede che la seconda città del
burkina faso
questo centro è diventato un po un punto
di riferimento nel quartiere per i
giovani anche per le loro famiglie e
questa è una soddisfazione enorme e
conoscere volto ogni volto ogni ragazzo
ogni nome la quadratura del cerchio di
questo progetto è sicuramente il momento
del festival ho battezzato nel gergo
della capoeira ossia il momento in cui
ogni anno mentre rai hilson e mostrando
pedro scendono in burkina faso e c'è un
evento che è bellissimo perché un
momento multiculturale ci sono ospiti
che arrivano da più parti del mondo è un
momento in cui i ragazzi sono
protagonisti perché danno una mano
nell'organizzazione e del momento in cui
mestre rais me strando pedro fanno
l'esame ragazzi per vedere il loro
livello di capo era perché non è un
regalo e capo era e disciplina e arte
marziale non ce lo dobbiamo dimenticare
e quindi l emozione per tutti per i
ragazzi prima di tutto e sicuramente in
questa fase ruolo di colón candia è
fondamentale perché è un supporto
necessario economico per permettere la
realizzazione del battezzato il festival
è di più perché tutti i ragazzi che
superano l'esame possono godere del
sostegno scolastico che è altrettanto
importante la parte educativa riuscire a
terminare le scuole non solo la comunque
è la base per costruire uomini
consapevoli donne consapevoli e devo
dire che tutta questa parte è la parte
più interessante
chiudo con un aneddoto una sera dopo un
grosso importante bellissimo allenamento
dica pure ragazzi mi hanno chiesto ma
perché ci insegni la capoeira e non
potevo raccontargli dell'importanza come
come strumento educativo dei ragazzi ho
cercato di trovare nel fondo di nel mio
più profondo
la parte più intima che cosa è per me la
capo era qual è la cosa per cui credo
che sia veramente uno strumento con i
ragazzi è iniziato così ragazzi pensate
agli schiavi
provate per un attimo soltanto mettervi
nei loro panni
la situazione peggiore per un essere
umano non già e libertà è invece di
finire ad abbruttiti a dare il peggio di
te hanno dato vita la capoeira a
qualcosa che permette attraverso un
gioco una disciplina di immaginare un
futuro migliore un futuro di libertà e
quindi spero per voi ragazzi che questa
cosa la cattura sia un vostro punto di
forza perché avrete mille momenti in cui
vi sarete giù di morale
avete dei momenti di difficoltà e spero
proprio in quei momenti la capoeira
possa con la sua disciplina essere
veramente una strada maestra per voi
e adesso un po della magia della
capoeira
grazie
[Musica]
ha detto
[Risate]
[Musica]
all
[Applauso]
[Musica]